LIKE THIS.
THEY WERE LUCKY TO GET THE
NUMBER ONE PICK IN A YEAR WHEN
YOU COULD GET SOMEONE LIKE CADE
CUNNINGHAM.
CHRIS: ON THE FLIPSIDE, IF CADE
CUNNINGHAM IS SMOOTH, EASY, CALM
AND COLLECTED, JALEN GREEN -- HE
IS THE BEST DRESSED, HE IS THE
FLAMBOYANT, HE IS THE GUY WITH
THE LONG HAIR AND THE SHINY
SUIT.
HE WENT SECOND OVERALL TO THE
HOUSTON ROCKETS.
HISTORY REPEATING ITSELF, 1970,
THE PISTONS AND ROCKETS HAD THE
FIRST AND SECOND SELECTION.
HERE IS TAYLOR ROOKS THE SECOND
PICK, JALEN GREEN.
TAYLOR: CONGRATULATIONS.
YOU SAID IT BEFORE THE DRAFT,
YOU WERE GOING TO GO TO ONE OF
THE TOP TWO TEAMS.
HOW EXCITED ARE YOU THAT YOU
LANDED IN HOUSTON?
JALEN: SUPER EXCITED.
THIS IS A DREAM COME TRUE.
I'M SO HAPPY.
TAYLOR: THIS IS THE THING ABOUT
YOU.
YOUR CONFIDENCE AND KILLER
MENTALITY.
THE ONE THING YOU SAID WAS THAT
WHOEVER PASSES UP ON YOU WAS
GOING TO PAY.
SEND A MESSAGE TO ALL THOSE
TEAMS THAT DON'T HAVE JALEN
GREEN ON THEIR SQUAD.
JALEN: I'M SORRY FOR YOU.
I'M GOING TO KEEP WORKING AND
GETTING BETTER EVERY DAY AND
PERFECTING MY CRAFT.
EVERY TIME I STEP ON THE FLOOR,
AND DETROIT ESPECIALLY, I'M
COMING.
TAYLOR: BIG TALK.
YOU SAID TWO OF YOUR GOALS WERE
TO BE ROOKIE OF THE YEAR AND
LAND ON THE ALL DEFENSIVE TEAM.
HOW WILL YOU DEVELOP INTO AN
ELITE TWO-WAY PLAYER WITH THE
ROCKETS?
JALEN: COACH SILAS TALKED ABOUT
DEFENSE THE WHOLE TIME DURING MY
TRIP OUT THERE.
I'M GOING TO LOCK IN AND TALK TO
HIM.
I'M GOING TO FOCUS ON THE
DEFENSIVE SIDE.
TAYLOR: IT WILL BE A JOY TO
WATCH YOU.
CONGRATULATIONS AND WELCOME TO
THE NBA.
JALEN: THANKS.
I APPRECIATE IT.
CHRIS: FOR THOSE JUST TUNING IN,
YOU COACHED HIM WITH THE
G-LEAGUE IGNITE.
CAN HE WIN ROOKIE OF THE YEAR?
OUR POLL SAYS HE CAN.
BRIAN: HE DEFINITELY CAN.
WHAT HE DID IN THE G-LEAGUE
AGAINST THE COMPETITION THIS
YEAR, AVERAGING A LITTLE UNDER
18 POINTS PER GAME, THE PLAYOFF
GAME WE PLAYED AGAINST TORONTO'S
TEAM, HE HAD 30 POINTS AND THEY
WERE DOUBLING AND TRIPLING HIM.
THEY HAD FIVE NBA GUYS ON THEIR
ROSTER.
I THINK THAT TRANSLATES TO WHAT
WE WILL SEE.
WHEN YOU SEE THE ATHLETICISM,
THE EFFORTLESS ATHLETICISM HE
WILL BRING TO THE TABLE AND THE
HIGHLIGHTS HE IS GOING TO
PRODUCE THIS YEAR, HE HAS A
GREAT CHANCE OF BEING ROOKIE OF
THE YEAR.
STEVE: I LOVE HIM.
HE HAS A FLAIR, A STYLE THAT
SAYS, LOOK AT ME.
WHEN YOU SAY COME LOOK AT ME,
YOU HAVE TO BACK IT UP.
I HAVE WATCHED HIM AND WHAT I
LOVE IS, I LOVE HIS OFFENSE BUT
I LOVE THAT HE TOOK CHALLENGES
DEFENSIVELY.
I THINK EVERYBODY KEPT SAYING
HE IS SMALL BUT WHEN YOU HAVE A
GUY THAT'S GOTTA WINGSPAN LIKE
THAT, THIS IS A GUY THAT CAN
FLAT OUT FLY.
IF YOU HAVE LONG ARMS, YOU CAN
BE A LITTLE SMALL.
WHEN YOU HAVE A GUY THAT CAN FLY
WITH LONG ARMS, AND HE HAS THIS
"I WANT TO BE GREAT," USUALLY
THOSE GUYS WILL GIVE YOU
EVERYTHING.
YOU HAVE TO TAILOR THEM DOWN.
I'M OK WITH TAILORING A GUY
DOWN.
ANDY: WHEN I LOOK AT THE
LOTTERY, AND I KNOW WE WILL GET
TO THIS BUT I DON'T KNOW IF
THERE IS ANOTHER PLAYER THAT
MATCHES A TEAM WHERE THE PLAYER
CAN BASICALLY DO WHAT HE DID THE
YEAR BEFORE FOR YOU IN THE NBA,
WHICH IS HIGH-VOLUME SHOTS.
BECAUSE IN HOUSTON, WHERE IT IS
A COMPLETE OVERHAUL, THEY NEED
SOMEONE TO MAKE SHOTS.
HE CAN MAKE SHOTS.
I DON'T THINK THEY WILL HOLD HIM
BACK, WHEREAS A LOT OF OTHER
PLAYERS HAVE TO SORT OF FIT INTO
THE SYSTEM OR FIND THEIR ROLE.
I THINK HE IS THE PERFECT FIT
FOR HOUSTON BECAUSE THEY NEED
SOMEONE LIKE HIM WHO WILL BE A
STAT STUFFER.
BRIAN: HE HAS A KNACK FOR
FIGURING IT OUT ON THE FLY.
THERE WERE TIMES THIS YEAR WHEN
HE HAD FOUR POINTS AT HALFTIME,
HE WOULD COME IN AND SAY, COACH,
WHAT ARE THEY DOING TO ME?
I WOULD SAY, THEY ARE SITTING ON
YOUR RIGHT HAND.
WHEN THEY GIVE YOU THE LEFT,
TAKE IT.
HE WOULD GO OUT AND SCORE 16
POINTS IN THE THIRD QUARTER.
HE WOULD FIGURE IT OUT.
HE HAD A KNACK FOR DOING THAT.
HE HAS A SLENDER, WIRY BODY.
ONE THING HE USED TO SAY ALL THE
TIME WAS, I'M NOT BACKING DOWN
FROM ANYONE.
WHAT YOU HEARD HIM SAY ABOUT,
ESPECIALLY WHEN WE PLAY DETROIT,
YOU GUYS ARE GOING TO SEE ME ON
POINT, BECAUSE HE IS REALLY MAD
HE WASN'T THE FIRST PICK IN THE
DRAFT.
THAT IS HIS MENTALITY THAT HE
BRINGS EVERY DAY.
HE DIDN'T MISS A SINGLE DAY OF
PRACTICE, A GAME, NOBODY BEAT
HIM IN A SPRINT AFTER PRACTICE
ON THE TEAM WAS RUNNING.
AND HE IS A STUDENT OF THE GAME.
WHEN YOU COMBINE THOSE
ATTRIBUTES AND QUALITIES THAT HE
BRINGS, HE IS ABSOLUTELY GOING
TO BE A STAR IN THE NBA.
CHRIS: WHO IS GOING TO HAVE THE
FLASHIER SUITS, JALEN GREEN OR
CALVIN MURPHY?
ANDY: I WILL GO CALVIN MURPHY.
BRIAN: I DON